(indistinct background chatter)
- I think we're about ready
to go and get started.
As everyone continues to take their seat,
I want to welcome you.
Good afternoon, everyone,
I'm Kim Goff-Crews,
and it is my privilege today
to welcome you to our ceremony
as we honor our veterans.
As we gathered together
with President Salovey,
Provost Strobel, officers
of the university,
the commanding officers of
our Naval and Air Force,
Reserve Officers Training Corps,
and all of you, our honored guests,
I'm also pleased to
extend a special welcome
to Brigadier General Donald
Singer and his wife Anne.
Welcome, thank you for being here.
(crowd claps)
Before we begin, I would also like
to thank the Yale Police
Department Color Guard
for the opening ceremony,
thank you very much.
And to share our land
acknowledgement, which states,
the university acknowledges
the indigenous peoples and nations,
including Mohegan, Mashantucket Pequot,
Eastern Pequot, Schaghticoke,
Golden Hill Paugussett,
Niantic, and the Quinnipiac
and other Algonquian speaking peoples,
who have stewarded through generations
the lands and waterways
of what is now the State of Connecticut.
We honor and respect the
enduring relationship
that exists between these peoples
and nations and this land.
So what a pleasure to be
with all of you outside
and in front of this
beautifully restored cenotaph
and university flagpole,
for the return of an official
ceremony to Hewitt Quadrangle.
The last two years have been
challenging, to say the least,
with understandable limits on
how we can gather together.
But somehow it feels fitting
that one of our first larger events
is one in which we can publicly recognize
the important contributions of veterans
to the life of the university.
We have with us today,
students, faculty, and staff,
and alumni who have served or
who are preparing to serve.
And we are grateful for
the freedoms and privileges
that their sacrifices have made possible.
During our ceremony today, as
you'll see on your program,
you will hear from a veteran
leader, a current student,
and we will also honor
a 47-year staff person,
not 47 years old, but
been here for 47 years.
And she supported most of that time
and advocated for Yale Veterans.
Our speakers and honoree represent
commitment to honor and country,
and to veterans across multiple
generations and conflicts.
They represent all the veterans
who are here with us today
and those who care and support them.
It is my pleasure now to
introduce President Peter Salovey,
who will share his thoughts
on our treasured veterans.
President Salovey.
(crowd claps)
- Thank you, Vice President Goff-Crews
Hello everyone.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for being here to
honor veterans past and present.
It's wonderful to be together.
It's wonderful to be in person together
to be on campus and to
recognize Veterans Day.
So we're joined today by
faculty, staff, students,
and alumni who are veterans,
as well as students who currently serve
in the Reserve Officers Training Corps
here on Yale's campus,
to all of our current and former members
of the armed forces, thank you.
With our very deepest
gratitude and respect.
Yale students, alumni, faculty and staff
have served their country honorably
for over three centuries.
We're proud of them.
We're proud of the rich legacy of service
that they represent.
We think of Nathan Hale,
Yale College class of 1773,
perhaps the most famous alumnus
to serve in the American Revolution.
We think of Cortlandt
Van Rensselaer Creed,
the first African American
to earn a medical degree from Yale.
Who in spite of tremendous
racism and discrimination
served in the Union Army
during the Civil War.
And we think of Rear Admiral Grace Hopper,
who received her master's
and PhD in mathematics
from Yale University.
When she retired from the
Navy, at the age of 79,
she was the oldest serving
officer in the U.S. Armed Forces.
Remembering the service
and sacrifice of veterans
is a responsibility we all share.
100 years ago on November 11th, 1921,
the Tomb of the Unknown Soldier
was dedicated in Arlington
National Cemetery,
as a place to honor and commemorate
American lives lost in war.
And Yale too shares in this history.
Ferdinand Foch, a French military leader,
who served as commander in chief
of the Allied Armies in World War I,
spoke at Arlington at the
funeral for The Unknown Soldier,
and the next day traveled to New Haven
where he received an
honorary degree from Yale.
Our university knew the terrible
cost of war all too well.
Here on Hewitt Quadrangle,
the Memorial Cenotaph honors
225 Yale's students and alumni
who died in the Great War
and carved into the
walls of Memorial Hall.
You can find the names of
1,020 alumni killed in battle
since the American Revolution.
Yale's tradition of
military service continues
with the students who
currently serve in Yale ROTC.
And this year we are particularly grateful
for their example of service.
The pandemic has reminded
us time and time again,
of the critical importance of
putting the needs of others
above our own.
Service is part of the Yale
veteran communities DNA.
We see that in the work of
the Yale Veterans Network,
a campus group for students,
faculty, and staff,
and the Yale Veterans Association
and alumni organization.
In the early days of the pandemic,
the Yale Veterans Network
supported the downtown
evening soup kitchen
helping provide meals to
our neighbors in New Haven.
Last winter, they
continued their tradition
of collecting toys
for the U.S. Marines
Toys for Tots Program,
which provides gifts for
children at the holidays.
The new co-chairs of the
Yale Veterans Network,
Shawn Flynn and Tamika Hollis,
are continuing to support
veterans within the Yale community
while also helping those in
need in the broader community.
I thank them for their service
as we honor the contributions
and sacrifices of all veterans.
At the going down of the
sun and in the morning,
we will remember them.
Thank you very much,
thank you for being here.
(crowd claps)
- Atten-hut!
Ready, halt!
("Star Spangled Banner")
Order, halt!
Ready, two!
- Grand architect of the universe
called by many names
in many languages by many voices.
Today, we ask that your
guiding hands hold us,
and all sisters and brothers
in military service near.
We are grateful for all who
serve, all who have served.
And for those who,
in the words of President Abraham Lincoln
"Gave the last full measure of devotion
"and service to their country."
We are joined in humility, gratitude,
and our own measure of devotion,
knowing that as we seek to understand
an increasingly complex world,
we are sheltered by the vigilant service
of citizens to our Republic.
We ask special regard for
those who have served,
but who have not yet been
found and returned home.
And for those who have returned home,
but who have yet to
find themselves at home.
We honor our military and ask that
whatever is required of them,
be informed by your infinite wisdom,
the light and the truth as
they honorably and loyally
seek to create a peaceful
and secure future for us all.
- Good afternoon, everyone.
First and foremost,
I'd like to give recognition and thanks
to President Salovey,
Secretary Goff-Crews,
Provost Strobel, Chaplain Kugler,
Tamika Hollis, Valerie Stanley,
and the Veterans Day committee.
I'd also like to personally thank
Dean Risa Sodi.
I'd like to thank head David Evans,
Dean Brianna Bilski and Damaris
Cardona of Berkeley College
for their constant support
over the last three years.
I'd also get to take a moment to recognize
and thank the men and women in uniform
and those in civil
service, law enforcement
and the fire department.
Last but not least, I wanna
thank my incredible parents
who are here in the front row
or second row right before me,
my father Tai and my mother Anh.
It is-
(crowd claps)
It was Veterans Day and
we're thanking our veterans,
but it's veteran families
who endure more hardship
than you could imagine.
They sit back and constant worry and fear
while we across the world during our job,
doing what we love,
and they stay in a state
of unrest and concern
not knowing the danger we
are in and what could happen.
To all in attendance,
thank you for coming.
It's an honor to be here
with you all on this day
to thank our veterans to
honor their sacrifices.
October 19th, 2001, the U.S.
Army 75th Ranger Regiment,
as part of a Special
Operations Joint Task Force,
parachute dropped in
(mumbles) in Afghanistan.
Army Rangers were then-
(clears throat) Excuse me,
continue to deploy to combat ever since.
Up until recently, that's
well over 7,000 days
of unbroken combat operations.
During this time 52 Army Rangers
gave the ultimate sacrifice
laying down their lives,
over 450 were wounded in action.
Many care, the physical wounds of war,
almost all carry the invisible scars.
They joined the service whole
and often leave pieces of
themselves in these distant lands.
Yet they would never leave
a fallen brother behind
and they will drive on
to complete the mission no matter what.
An Army Ranger chooses this,
he volunteers for it,
fully knowing the hazards
of his chosen profession.
He accepts the fact as the ranger,
his country expects him to move further,
faster than fight harder
than any other soldier.
Arranger will shoulder more
than his share of the task
100% and then some.
It's not for the money,
he makes not much more
than if he chose a regular
9 to 5 non-combat job.
It's not for the benefits
you get the same,
if you chose a less hazardous specialty
with a shorter enlistment contract.
It's not for the work-life balance,
he trains for 7 months and
deploys 4 months every year,
giving up time with his
family and loved ones.
So why does he do it?
He does it for the man
to his left and his right
to protect his loved ones back home,
for all of us civilians
stateside right now,
regardless of whether
you support him or not,
he's willing to sacrifice
everything for you.
Many have given the ultimate sacrifice
and may they never be forgotten.
I'm proud of serving
the 75th Ranger Regiment
proud to have deployed
twice to Afghanistan
with 1st Ranger Battalion.
Lucky to be standing
here with you all today
and grateful to all
veterans before and after me
who have answered the call
with selfless service.
My motivation to join the military
was rooted in my parents' sacrifice,
to leave their homes in Vietnam
in search of a better
life for their families.
They were just kids.
My father was a teenager,
with no other choice would
have to leave his own father
and everything he knew behind
to embark on a dangerous
journey to some far off land.
This far off land was the United States,
and it gave my family an
opportunity at a better life,
the chance to give back
to this great nation
that welcomed my family
and gave them opportunity
to protect the freedom that my parents
risked their lives to have
for me, that alone was worth fighting for.
I remember when I finished the
first phase of Ranger School,
I'd lost about 15 pounds in 20 days
and had essentially been
drained of all my strength.
When I pitifully jogged out of the gates
of the training compound
for my 8 hour break or pass,
I was in shock to see my parents,
who had driven down to Georgia
from New York to surprise me.
Due to exhaustion I don't remember much
of those next 8 hours,
but I do remember my mother
and father caring for me,
all my fingers were infected and swollen
to the point of immobility,
but I do remember coming
in and out of sleep
to my mother cleaning each
of my fingers and nails.
I remember sitting at a buffet
right before having to go
back to the training compound
and seeing the looks on my parents' faces
as they watch me struggle
to simply lift the glass
of water to my mouth.
The next two weeks in Ranger School
were among the most physically
difficult in my life.
I'd essentially lost almost
all strength and control
on my arms and fingers.
I tore and re-tore the ligaments
in my ankles repeatedly
only for me to be supported
by a tight tie of the boots.
Yet everyday I continued to get
that 90-pound rucksack on my back
and just did what I had to do,
to be a contributing member on my team.
So what's the lesson here?
Well, in hindsight, if
you're in that condition,
it's highly recommended
to go see a physician.
But I tell this story
because it highlights
the first impactful
lesson from the military
that I wanted to share with you,
is the power of your 'why'
and how important it is
to not only identify it,
but to never lose sight of it.
Never once, did I consider
quitting in those weeks
when your why is strong
enough, the how is irrelevant.
as Viktor Frankl said in his book,
"Man's Search For Meaning,
"suffering ceases to be suffering
"at the moment it finds a meaning."
My "why" in Ranger School,
"Remember what you promised your family,
"yourself and your brothers."
That was my "Why".
I wrote that sentence in Sharpie,
underneath the brim of my patrol cap.
So that every time I was
feeling sorry for myself
in a low point, I get down on a knee,
remove the cap from my head
and read it to remind myself
why I had to keep going,
over the next three months,
blood, sweat, and dirt
was stained into that cap.
And when I finished the course,
I gave it to my father who
still has it to this day.
The writing on it is blurred
and almost illegible,
but it can be read.
Often, your "Why" may be hard to see,
but I promise you it's there,
if you look hard enough.
The second lesson for my
service that I'll share,
"Do something difficult every day."
Why would I give so much during training?
I mean, this was just a
Ranger School after all,
it wasn't Afghanistan.
But that's what Special
Operations emphasizes,
"How you do small things
is how you do all things."
It's important to learn about who you are
at your lowest point,
to test your character,
when at rock bottom.
In Ranger School, I was constantly in pain
and asking myself the
question many of us do
when we were facing something difficult.
"How long will this last?"
Instead, I encourage you
to ask, "How far can I go?"
If I couldn't push myself further then,
how could I be expected to push
further when I was deployed,
when there was much more
in the line in combat.
The only way I could
truly learn about myself
and how far I could really go,
was by doing something
difficult every day,
and that was life and Ranger Regiment.
However, I'll admit that
was a different environment.
It was easier for me to choose difficult
because there was much more
at stake than just myself,
after all that was preparation for combat.
It is far, far easier to
choose what it's easy,
when things don't go the way
where they're supposed to,
it is human nature to
put the blame elsewhere.
So in these moments,
I challenge you to look
deep within yourself.
Life is pain in struggle,
it's inevitable in life
that you'll find yourself
facing bad situations,
but it's how you face these difficulties
that will determine your fate.
Your obstacles are not these
things, events, or people,
the obstacle is yourself.
See the role you played in any failure,
it can always be found.
As Viktor Frankl wrote,
"When we are no longer able
to change the situation,
"we are challenged to change ourselves,
"so choose difficult, you
will learn more about yourself
"and will be better for it."
When I left the Ranger
Regiment and came to Yale,
the transition was very difficult.
At the end of my first year,
I wrote an article describing
some of my thoughts
as a veteran who recently
left the service.
Initially I did not want to publish it,
but I realized that it wasn't about me.
I realized that I was fortunate
to be part of an incredible
institution here at Yale,
privileged to have a platform
that could reach a large audience
and that my article could serve as a voice
for all the veterans out
there who don't have one.
The veterans who may not want
to or may not know how to,
directly express their thoughts
to their friends and family,
and just maybe they could possibly share
this article with them instead.
If I somehow was able to
reach this one veteran
with that message, that
would make it all worth it.
In the article I said that,
"Civilians did not need to
understand us to care about us."
However, after some thought,
I do believe that asking others to care,
maybe a bit of an overstep.
I sit alongside peers
that don't truly comprehend
the events of 911.
War is a far away concept,
blurred by distance,
experienced through screens.
Skin in the game, is one thing
that goes through my mind,
every time I have to
evaluate someone's motivation
on a matter, their capacity to truly care.
See today, unlike previous generations,
far fewer individuals
have a direct connection
to military service.
We have far fewer people who
have ever worn the uniform,
who've ever experienced from
the firsthand perspective
of what it means to serve in sacrifice.
But whether they've
experienced war or not,
it's important to understand
that veterans willingness
to sacrifice everything
cannot be forgotten.
It must be honored.
I believe that there was
much progress to be made
if individuals seek to try
to understand their veterans.
So I will conclude this speech
by trying to do just that,
helping others understand their veterans,
even if it's just a tiny bit better.
Many veterans spent large
portions of their lives,
give their youths to
fight for the generations
that come after them.
They risk their lives hoping to make way
for a better tomorrow,
so that those who are not yet born
would have the opportunity
to live in a better world.
Some of us matured quicker
because the world showed us
it's dark side at a young age.
We trained and fought together,
regardless of any differences among us,
these were our brothers.
Brotherhood had nothing to do with
how we felt about each other.
It didn't matter what we
thought about each other,
or if we would hang out with
each other outside of work,
but when it came down to it,
we would die for each other.
That's brotherhood.
We serve for similar reasons.
We signed up and fought for
those that we love back home,
fellow American citizens
that we did not know,
and for those oppressed in a foreign land.
It didn't matter what race they were,
or what religion they believed in,
or what side of politics they supported.
None of that mattered
when we were out there,
what mattered was the man
to our left and right,
and the core values that we
were willing to die to protect.
We're not invincible, as much
as we used to like to think
and convince ourselves that
we were, war humbled us.
We had this idea from the media,
or video games, or the recruiter,
on what would be so glorious about it.
But once that protective bubble burst,
and it suddenly sat in
that death could very
much become a reality,
it was a humbling experience.
We don't particularly
miss the war on combat,
we missed the brotherhood, the camaraderie,
knowing exactly what we do for each other
without hesitation, that
is what we miss the most.
Many veterans struggled with depression
when they return home,
not because they long
for the pity of others,
but because they are searching
again for a purpose, a "Why."
When we're over there,
we dreamt about how amazing
it would be to go home.
But when we get home,
we realize that life
carried on without us,
that we were never really needed here.
Veterans returned to what seems like
a bubble of access materialism,
cynicism, and ingratitude,
and find themselves stripped to the roles
they'd spent years of their lives
devoting their blood and sweat to.
Over there people relied
on us, we were needed.
Even if it wasn't what we
initially volunteered for,
it was outside of this country
that we find a purpose.
Military personnel are like a strong seal.
They endure a heavy amount of pressure
and showing no external
signs of stress or damage
until they just break.
From personal experience,
I can say that the military teaches you
to separate your mind from your emotions.
You cannot survive in combat
unless you've mastered this task.
Emotional thinking can
lead to second guessing,
second guessing can lead to hesitation,
and hesitation could
lead to injury or death.
Therefore, this ability is like a switch
that one must flip on and off.
It spills over to one's
personal life and relationships.
Then you were told that
you were cold-hearted
because you no longer
express yourself emotionally,
and you begin to drift apart.
Then it seems that the only people
that understand or relate to you
are those with which you served.
You find yourself closer to
them than your actual family,
your spouse, your civilian friends.
It can lead to a very difficult time
adjusting to civilian norms.
In the military and combat
it's imperative to exist without emotion,
yet, emotions are what we
are genetically programmed
to express and display in
everyday civilian life.
That is what makes the life of a veteran
extremely difficult.
Everyone seems to love as
soldier until they come home.
They don't ask us about our
experiences for the most part,
not because they don't want to disturb us,
but it's because they're
afraid of being disturbed
by what it takes for
them to be safe and free.
We sleep sound under a
warm blanket of freedom,
unbothered and not knowing
that these rough individuals will do,
and go to the farthest ends to protect us.
The thought that freedom and safety
is not a given birthright
is an uncomfortable truth
to the normal civilian.
You may wonder why that's
so surprising to you
that some combat veterans are lost here
and want to actually go back to war.
A reason to consider is that
it's a selfless society in war
and comparatively, civilian
life is individualistic.
Soldiers who are deploy as a cohesive unit
come back to society of individuals
who do not behave as a unit.
Most relationships that
people have with each other
nowadays are shallow.
Most don't know their neighbors.
People in universities often spend years
seeing each other in lectures
and never come to
genuinely know each other.
With technology and social media,
our generation has been
trained to be isolated
from human contact and
each day this creates
a more isolated situation for each.
As citizens, we are
responsible for a society.
We must strive to have respect for things,
for people that we do not understand.
We must not be individuals in society
who seek echo chambers,
we self categorize and tribalize,
because what this does
is breaks apart the American tapestry.
You must not fail to see the big picture
and remember that there are things
much more important than ourselves,
such as maintaining respect
for differing opinions
and remaining United as a nation,
because it is a selfless
respectful thing to do,
because that matters
more to the greater good.
We must not become preoccupied
with attempting to
dictate change to society
before looking inside ourselves first.
Thus, if we were more introspective
and less determined to bend
the world to our ideology,
we would by definition, be more unified.
The question for each one of us is,
how do we begin to unite?
Humility and perspective
will be our greatest
teachers moving forward.
Keep humility close to your
heart and maintain perspective,
and together we can solve so
many more challenges in life.
Humility and perspective allow
us to learn from each other.
I speak to you, to my fellow
veterans you are among
some of the best trained
individuals in the world.
You underwent a transformation as I have
in order to stay vigilant and be alive
in a place that prides itself
on taking you out without cause.
You will never be the same,
but the truth is you will be better.
Some days will be harder than others,
but the piece will come in time.
One day you'll realize
just how far you've come
and the struggles you face
won't feel so intimidating
because you realize you've
conquered so many before.
Even if the pain is still there,
you realize it may always
be, and somehow, that's okay.
As Victor Frankel wrote,
"What is to give light
must endure burning."
When a bone breaks and aligns
incorrectly in your body
a doctor will often have to re-break it
in order for you to heal properly,
the same is true for the ego.
Past trauma or the
circumstance of the world
can cause our mind to align incorrectly,
this healing may require a breaking.
I say to you, it will
always be okay in the end,
if it's not okay, it's not the end.
Think back to a year ago,
do you remember what was bothering you?
Is it still bothering you?
What you were going through will pass.
Use hindsight is foresight,
you'll be grateful for it.
When we honor Veterans Day,
we remember our veterans,
it's important for us to
remember the incalculable debt
that is owed to you, to our veterans,
a debt that's impossible
to ever repay fully,
but it is a debt that is essential for us
to always remember,
to never forget the true cost of freedom,
and who carries the burden of that cost.
As a fellow veteran, your
struggle is my struggle,
your anger and frustration
are my anger and frustration.
Your pain is my pain, your
challenges are my challenges.
Your failures and successes
are my failures and successes.
My service pales in comparison
to great individuals
who've come before me,
who've paved the way,
to true warriors like Bobby Atkinson,
Sam Myers, James Hatch.
(clears throat) Excuse me.
Who also attend this great university
and provide more value
than most will ever know.
I'm not a hero, I served with real heroes.
Those who wake up every
single day at 5:00 AM
and put their boots and uniform on,
when nobody has any idea where they're at,
or the things they're doing,
and to those who can never return.
And for the gold star
families who carry on today
without sons, daughters, fathers,
and mothers, I honor you.
To Staff Sergeant Jason Dockery,
Private First Class Eric Hario,
Corporal Andrew Amesbury,
Staff Sergeant Avonye Chisolm,
Sergeant First Class Christopher Celiz,
Specialist Etienne Murphy,
Sergeant First Class Ethan Carpenter,
these are just a few great men
who serve as part of my reason
why today and every day,
to all the veterans who have served,
thank you for your sacrifices you've made
and continued to make.
You have given this country a privilege
that's beyond payment.
We honor you for that today
and every day, thank you.
(crowd claps)
(Color Guard commands)
("Taps")
- (sighs) I don't know about you,
I feel the need to just
kind of like breathe
for just a second, that was
very, very impactful speech,
Andrew, thank you very much as well.
From time to time, the
university recognizes
outstanding contributions to veterans,
with the Veterans Day Tribute Award,
and this year is my great
honor to present the award
to Valerie Stanley, senior director
of the office of institutional
equity and accessibility.
Now in a moment, Valerie
will make her way here
so we can actually give her award,
but actually is when I want to tell you
a little bit about why
the committee thought
this was appropriate.
Many of you may know the
Valerie has been on staff
for 47 years, as I mentioned,
that's like 47 years.
(chuckles) And for 44 of those years,
she has been involved in
crafting policy and plans
to comply with federal
requirements in areas,
including Title VI, the ADA, Title IX
Section 504 and Age
Discrimination, to name a few.
In fact, in the late 1970s,
Valerie helped write the
university's first affirmative
action and equal opportunity
plan for the United States
Department of Health,
Education and Welfare.
She worked 14 straight days
using typewriters and carbon paper.
Now, if you don't know what that is,
you can just see me later, okay?
(crowd laughs)
But what many of you may not know
is that Valerie has also
been for all of those years
an outstanding and a really long-term ally
for our veterans.
In her early days, she
had a special affinity
and affection for Vietnam veterans
who often felt unwelcome on their return,
and were hesitant to share their service
and experience with the old colleagues.
She would support them and
she continues to support them
however she could.
In 2011, Valerie began working
with Debbie Stanley McCauley,
who is the associate vice president
for employee engagement
and workplace culture.
And she worked to
advocate for the creation
of a new affinity group on
campus for staff veterans.
As a result, we now have
the Yale Veterans Network,
a Yale community of veterans,
veteran leaders and allies,
who support and encourage each other,
in addition to advocating
for veteran recruitment,
career development, growth and retention.
And today that network,
the Yale Veterans Network is thriving
and Valerie serves and continues to serve
on its steering committee.
In addition to supporting these veterans,
Valerie has made a point to
help all students in particular
understand the veteran experience.
Valerie, you're going
to retire in December
after 47 years at Yale,
but before you go,
I am so pleased to present
you with this award
on behalf of the Veterans Day
committee and the university
in recognition of your support,
your longterm support
for veterans at Yale,
please join me and
accepting this small token
of our admiration and respect (mumbles)
and your contributions.
Thank you very, very much.
(crowd claps)
(mumbles)
- Thank you Kim and thank you everyone.
I don't have a prepared speech,
but I do want to just
express my sincere thanks
to the veterans committee
for choosing me today.
I'm not a veteran, I don't have a story.
Andrew has the perfect, wonderful story,
and all of the rest of you
who have served this country
have equally important
and wonderful stories.
Even if you haven't had the
opportunity to share them
with anybody else.
Maybe you have with your
family, may be no one,
maybe it's just something
that's in your head,
but your stories are all important.
Everything you've done is important.
All I've tried to do is to support you
in the best way that I could,
in the best way that I know how,
and I am truly, truly honored
to accept this award from you all
and this recognition after I
was only two when I started.
So, (chuckles) that's my
story, I'm sticking to it.
Those of you who know me for a while now,
I've had that story for a long time.
But anyway, thank you all so much.
It is truly an honor and a pleasure.
I'm going to miss you all,
but I live in New Haven,
I'll be around and I'm sure
I'll see some of you around.
Thank you.
(crowd claps)
("The Armed Forces Medley")
- I invite you to stand
please for The Benediction,
Let us go forth from this
place of profound memory
and deep meaning with grateful hearts.
Grateful for the service and
sacrifice of our veterans
and their families.
Let us never forget all they have done
to bravely protect
freedom and human rights.
From the moment our veterans
made the commitment to serve
they were committing to a life
that would be forever changed.
May we be ever mindful
that the life of a veteran
is always multi-dimensional
and is rooted in the pride
and promise of liberation
coupled with the ever-present possibility
of peril or alienation.
All of these things are held intention
and contain a longing for
a certain kind of peace
to revive our weary world.
As we honor our veterans
and we seek to grow closer
to this abiding peace,
may we come to know
a peace born from wisdom
and understanding,
a peace nurtured with
compassion and mercy,
a peace strengthened by
courage and commitment.
And may we be blessed
this day and every day
by the shimmering light
of our God of many names,
our God who creates, sustains
and embraces all life,
for this we say, Amen.
(Color Guard commands)
- Right turn, march!
Forward march!
- Well, this concludes our ceremony.
And with passed and
return to our busy life,
I hope that we will continue
to remember the women and men of Yale
who have faithfully taken
oath to protect and serve.
Remember that they are the reason
why we can pursue our "why's"
and why we can build a better community.
We are stronger and diverse
community because of them.
Many thanks to the planning committee
and our ceremony participants as well,
A special thanks to Tom Duffy
and the Yale School of
Music Brass Ensemble,
for sharing with us,
moving inspiring music.
Thank you for all that you do.
(crowd claps)
Thank you, everybody and enjoy your day.